so today we're gonna discuss the highest
caffeinated beverage in the world okay
so let me know what you think it is with
the comment down below all right before
we cover that I want to just mention
there's there's a half-life of caffeine
in other words it there's a point where
it breaks down so no longer has its
effect and that is usually between four
to six hours now of course if your liver
is damaged if you have a fatty liver if
you have cirrhosis if you have hepatitis
this is going to be extended to the
point where could even reach up to a
hundred hours so it's basically floating
around your system and you're not going
to be able to sleep okay so if you drink
coffee and have problems sleeping then
it could be the liver needs to be
addressed okay the point is that there
are certain enzymes that are supposed to
get rid of this chemical and the liver
is responsible for that now the next
point I want to talk about is the
caffeine molecule is very similar to
another molecule called adenosine okay
adenosine signals it's sleep time time
for bed
so if you don't have enough adenosine
you're not going to be able to feel like
you're tired you're not gonna be able to
go to sleep at night and caffeine can
lock up the receptors for this adenosine
and just prevent you from sleeping
that's why it's important to have a good
liver and it's also important not to
overdo it on the caffeine now do I drink
coffee
yes but I only drink one small cup in
the morning probably the size of a tea
cup it's because I had a history of
abusing coffee large amounts and it
affected my sleep big-time I think most
people consume too much caffeine and
they probably should cut it back
especially if it's affecting your sleep
and other health aspects but our world
collectively consumes about a hundred
million metric tons of caffeine every
single year were fully addicted alright
now let's talk about what beverage has
the most caffeine of anything okay so
start with Starbucks a 16-ounce has 500
and 15 milligrams that's quite high
Starbucks 12-ounce has 260 milligrams
5-hour energy drink two ounces has 215
milligrams
Red Bull 8.4 ounces has 80 milligrams of
caffeine black tea 12 ounce has 62
milligrams of caffeine a coke 12 ounce
has 34 milligrams of caffeine of course
a lot of sugar to jolt remember jolt
that soda 16 ounce has 160 I thought it
would be a lot more than that
okay so now I'm going to review the
beverage that has the most caffeine
which is 1555 milligrams of caffeine of
a 12 ounce size and that is black label
devil Mountain coffee so they basically
add caffeine into this coffee to make it
over a thousand this is completely and
utterly insane how much caffeine is in
there so if you decide to consume this
maybe you should only have like a coffee
the size of this little cap right here
okay maybe a half of an ounce I think
that's that's your limit alright okay
guys thanks for watching hey guys I'm
not sure if you have my app yet dr. Berg
app it's totally free you should
download it okay this is what it looks
like you click it it gives you all sorts
of great resources I have all my youtube
videos on this out okay and it's
regularly uploading the most recent ones
all the YouTube videos are also
converted to audio versions okay so you
can use it when you're walking
exercising driving your car I have a
mini course on there I'll be putting
additional courses I have a lot of
recipes on there this is new and also a
PDF resources so there's various
downloads PDFs that you can get as well
and if you wouldn't mind after you
download it check it out give me your
unbiased review and tell me how you like
it
I want to know